i stayed because the cooperation give
roger weber and satisfied so in
principle until it is again
one is two
circumcision that means the clitoris
and part of the small labia were
removed the patient
actually had hope was big enough
and there he has it  no
physical problems either, but the really
big problem with these patients is of
course this psychological
damage, that they have the feeling
that their whole life is
what has been stolen from them and and that was what they
have restored as well as possible in order to feel whole  how
can a kitsch is there again you get
you first the skin is taken
or it works so
the clitoris itself can of course
not be welcomed that has partly
gone but only the upper part is always
removed a bit so that you can hold
the extension
transition statements now and
can bring up so far that he can be seen again
how effective is the method
is fcm after an operation it
's done has the building works again
nicely or on tv the conversations are coming
wants an operation but also cold
the aftercare that is extremely important
especially his wife who has right
now the other has no self-esteem
you can't do that again alarm in
which you are now just an
antibiotic is reconstructed
there was a lot of psychological
support
to decide
how it came about I went to my
gynecologist and he recommended it to me
tores hiked up so
that they will just do it
let's reconstruct it like this say i'll wait
first i have to think about it
i was scared of course also because i
also had nightmares that i died from it
and so on until 11 may 2015 i
can also join a
self-help group and then i
just did it  then decided to
let michael freeze, we're going to be
much, much better outside now
I'm still a bit in pain but yes I feel
very good because for me it's
like something was taken away from me and it's
back
I'm totally impressed by your courage
and also by the open words I
don't know but for me it is  It's
important to say something because I'm far
too easy not to say anything and that did
n't help me much, it
just pulled me
back, so to speak,
I was just sent away for me
or I was just on my
own and I think man
should talk about it openly
, we simply don't have that chance in
africa